The Joe Rogan Experience but it is kind
of like a secret world deal like you
have to punch the code in to get into
the door or you have a key fob you know
that's kind of like subcultures have
always interested me there's always
sub-roser right yeah you know this the
Subrosa world of the the inside whether
it's comedians or stun guys or cops or
military there's always that Inn that in
Click and I think that's what fascinates
a lot of people a lot of times because
they want to be part of that little
we're originally going to name um some
people give me [__] because we called
number three Parabellum and then number
four was like just done with four Yeah
we actually had a title for John Wick 4
it was called haga Curry
um Japanese word that Lily meant like
hidden leaves it was A Treatise on
samurai code of ethics and
it really spoke to it was kind of like
the art of the way of dying like how do
you prepare yourself for a good death
and a lot of it dealt with you can only
relate to people
a warrior can only relate to a warrior
you know whether you're on other sides
or not a cop can only relate to a cop
and like you know whatever a teacher can
already do a teacher that inside sub-ro
is a thing that only each other knew
each other kind of thing we got it but
we didn't want to put a you know a title
on it
kind of lost it but I thought it was a
really cool thing about being sub Rose
or being in the inside Cliff or
something
yeah maybe on the next one why'd you
decide just it was like you know it was
the the actual Treatise it was from like
1646 or something like that
unfortunately it had been used
uh during World War II as a rallying cry
uh for a militaristic Japan to get
behind so in in some Asian markets it it
could be considered could be a problem
and we didn't want to take a chance it
was kind of yeah Japan Korea like okay I
get it we don't we want to be sensitive
to that but we still thought it was a
cool name yeah
it's uh it's what a weird world it is to
make films and then have them be
distributed worldwide it it's because
you you know it's like I'm sure you know
you're always going to piss off somebody
yeah you're always going to get
something or somebody can be something
so you just again I I like doing the
fantasy film kind of thing I like
creating our own worlds I like doing
that because it's ours and it's not
taking aside it's not really
uh I don't have to adhere to history I
have to adhere to an IP you can kind of
just do our thing and I think that kind
of Freedom helps a lot
you know I don't think people get
I know it's bent out of shape sometimes
on that because you're creating your own
world do you feel like
there's another there's room for another
thing like this in your life like is
this something you're going to try to do
again like recreate an entire ecosystem
an entire world
that's a good question I and I will
again like we like we say it was
unintentional completely unintentional
almost a fluke we did one then we did we
didn't know I didn't know anything about
the Continentals worldwide or the
marketers or anything until the second
one we made that up the third one we're
like oh let's call it the high table
sure someone will buy that sure and we
just keep you know kind of riffing on
stuff to do and just use your
imagination but it works it does and I I
think again and it works at a teacher
Continental too that it's International
like when he goes to Italy and he goes
and gets suited right well with that
that was probably one of my favorite
things I love the suit I love you know
that actor whoever that actor was that
is explaining to him the guns and oh uh
what is it Peter uh serranovitz yeah
yeah he was in a couple he was in um
the suits and the guns like this whole
scene that guy right there the the ball
guy right there yeah that's Luka Moscow
that's actually my wardrobe supervisor I
couldn't cast somebody in times I made
him do it and then Peter savonovitz this
guy he's so [__] funny yeah you just
buy him as a complete psycho that's he
he literally flew in on the day learned
the Lions did the gig and flew out
really yeah he was awesome wow he's
incredible I what was that movie Spy
with Statham oh yeah it was the Italian
he played the Italian spot he was so
funny so the guy that's doing the
Wardrobe was your actual wardrobe yeah I
couldn't I couldn't I kept telling like
people would come in and start reading
I'm like just be like my guy here be
like and we couldn't find anybody to be
Luca here and Luca was so set on like ah
[__] it look I put on you're doing it
dude you're doing it and he never acted
never acted before he's like crazy he's
fantastic he's great